le secteur de la restauration fait
partie des plus touchés par la crise
sanitaire nous sommes allés à la
rencontre d'un patron de restaurant dans
le 19e arrondissement de la capitale
pour savoir comment il se débrouille
estelle farges reportage
je suis dans le 19e arrondissement de
paris je vais rencontrer olivier les
restaurateurs depuis deux ans les
restaurateurs vite avec la crise
sanitaire alors dans quel état d'esprit
et il commet s'organise-t-il on va aller
lui demander
bonjour olivier bonjour reste à leur
merci beaucoup de nous recevoir dans
votre restaurant merci à vous olivier ça
fait trois ans que vous êtes ouverts
dont deux sont crise sanitaire comment
ça va ça va comme des gens dont on dit
qu'ils ont dit
la politique commerciale qui doivent
mener donc c'est plutôt tendue on est
dans une situation extrêmement tendue
actuellement aujourd'hui donc on a le
pass vaccinale avant il y avait le pass
sanitaire est ce que ça a changé
concrètement le seul changement de passe
ça nous a coupé d'une certaine clientèle
on a le télétravail
aussi qui le nous le midi ça nous
impacte on a quasiment moins 70 % de
chiffre d'affaires après le soir vous
clientèle aussi de jeunes et ses acquis
qui aujourd'hui a appris aussi à faire
la fête dit autrement au moment de
l'apéro tapas docu de consommation
debout plus de consommation au comptoir
et c'est sur des choses qui sont en
dehors un petit peu des modes de
fonctionnement d'une certaine clientèle
donc toute cette clientèle là on la perd
non seulement la paire mais je fais sûr
que cela protège parce que à côté de ça
il se retrouve dans des apparts où là il
ya aucun contrôle là où il n'y a aucune
mesure de distanciation et caetera et
donc finalement eu cela change pas
grand-chose à leur vie et par contre ça
pénalise l'économie et nos business
après je pense qu au niveau de
l'information il ya eu
une campagne qui a été pas suffisante il
ya beaucoup de gens qui étaient un petit
peu perdues savait pas comment ils
passaient de passes sanitaire a pas ce
vaccinale
voilà qu'on avait tous les gens qui
venaient et qui fonctionnait avec les
tests incluent aujourd'hui n'ont plus
accès s'ils rentrent pas dans un schéma
vaccinal nous c'est pas à nous de
décider si c'est bien ou c'est mal nous
on a juste à appliquer ce qu'on fait
donc aujourd'hui on est un petit peu le
bras armé la politique gouvernementale
sur ce sujet là aujourd'hui avec le
passé vaccinale les restaurateurs sont
aussi autorisés à contrôler l'identité
de leurs clients vous comment est-ce que
quel est votre regard sur ce qui a été
décidé sur votre nouveau rôle entre guy
moi je vérifie les passes mais je
vérifie pas les pièces d'identité je ne
demande pas des policiers de venir faire
la cuisine chez moi faut pas me demandez
moi on dit si on a un doute mais sur
quelle base je veux avoir un doute
croyons va créer dont va créer du
conflit on va créer de la tension est
réellement en ce moment c'est déjà
suffisamment tendue pour qu'on n'ait pas
besoin de se rajouter des situations
conflictuelles avec notre clientèle un
qui déjà continuent à venir ici depuis
l'entrée en vigueur des nouvelles
mesures restrictives on vous demande
encore des consommations au bar vous
quelque chose que vous êtes amené à
refuser savez c'est culturel les
personnes qui s'arrêtent la journée ils
ont envie de leur petit café petit café
vert d'eau ils ont pas du temps de
s'asseoir ils ont envie de le prendre là
comme ça rapidement deux minutes ils
prennent leur petit café ils s'en vont
aujourd'hui on leur dit non si vous
voulez on peut aller s'asseoir
olivier vous ayez une baisse de chiffre
d'affaires de 70 % comment est-ce que ça
va se passer maintenant pour vous au
niveau des aides alors il ya plusieurs
aides qu'ils auront été mises en place
par le gouvernement dont notamment pour
les mois de décembre et janvier
globalement un jour nuit sur le mois de
décembre j'ai fait -32% donc sur un
palier où on est sous les 30% où on est
on a une lettre qui est déclenché de
quel montant sous quelle forme j'en sais
rien mon comptable m'a dit que eux mêmes
avaient une formation qui me reviendrait
vers mois après ayez donc on est sur des
choses qui sont un petit peu complexe
puisque le mode de calcul des aides a
complètement changé depuis le dernier
confinement ça fait deux ans qu'on est
sans visibilité que systématiquement on
peut pas se projeter à plus de quelques
semaines
donc là on espère que tout va se rouvrir
bientôt février ou mars mais même là
c'est compliqué investir se projeter sur
l'été faire des investissements pour
l'été on bloque tout en permanence parce
qu'on se dit
qu' on n'est pas l'abri de nouvelles
mesures restrictives et dans ce cas là
c'est de l'argent perdu c'est de
l'argent jeté en l'air quel regard vous
portez sur sur l'avenir la concrètement
j'espère très sincèrement que on va s'en
sortir sinon je fais partie de ce
qu'envisage grands de faire autre chose